we understand that you brought Black
Russian to this years AFM is that
correct correct
what was your strategy going there going
there
well the strategy was to pitch a film
that had a relevant constructor concept
that being narco-terrorism and you know
in the movie itself takes place in
perhaps arguably the one of the most
dangerous parts of the world currently
which is the Pakistan India border
region and around Afghanistan and the
the the pitch was that you know we have
a very interesting screenplay that takes
place in this backdrop and the story
itself is a it's fundamentally a
kidnapping story it's a story of a Los
Angeles based lawyer who goes in search
of his fiancee but the backdrop is you
know very compelling so it's a it's a
story that we've heard before like you
know obviously seen films like taken man
on fire and so forth but we decided to
shoot it in this environment to make it
more 21st century or as we say 2013
what's current here in the US and you I
guess well we were doing the screenplay
he was interesting that you know the
SEAL team had captured and killed Osama
bin Laden at that point and this was
going on while we were in pre-production
so it gave us a little bit more I
suppose motivation to really get and get
our story out there because it became a
relevant issue we we see that part of
the world from a certain lens and what I
wanted to do was show that part of the
world from sort of the the community's
point of view and at the same time tell
a story that hopefully people will find
very interesting
so in synopsis the the strategy the AFM
was to go there and say look you know I
know that you know you don't know me I'm
not you know I'm not your mainstream
filmmaker I'm not you know anyone who's
to a big studio but I have a compelling
story and I have something I think
audiences across the board here with
weather here in the US or abroad and be
interested in what type of prep work did
you do beforehand to get yourself ready
to go whether it was just administrative
getting Flyers ready or whatever okay
well the main thing about a lot of what
happened at the AFM this year was also a
learning experience for me but before
going into any type of festival or or
gathering it's really good to know all
the players so you really have to do a
lot of research and the first thing to
do is to find out who's going to be at
the AFM so that's a critical component
so you actually contact the AFM and find
out which of Enders are going to be
there which production houses are going
to be there which distributors are going
to be there and then you painstakingly
slowly start the process one by one
contacting everybody because when you're
an independent production and you don't
know anybody then you want to reach out
to everyone and sure people are gonna
slam the door in your face and or put
the phone down on you rather but you
want to contact as many people as
possible and set up as many appointments
as possible to pitch your story in your
concept before you know before going
into the AFM some filmmakers will have a
completed film some will have a film
that needs financing others will have
one that's actually being shot in our
situation we were in post-production so
since our film was already fully
financed that gave us a little bit of an
edge I think the other thing that I was
pushing for in post-production was to
finish our trailer and a couple of reels
before we went to the AFM which we were
able to accomplish and I think that
really really helped a lot in regards to
securing appointments because when
you're talking to the person on their
side they're like bull would ya what do
you have to show us and we're like okay
well let's you know here's the trailer
go online and look at it and then as
soon as we got the production houses to
look at the trailer or the distributor's
they were interested they're like oh
this is pretty
trailer you know can we see the film and
we're like well not yet
because you know even though I could
have showed him a rough cut I didn't
want to because I'm very protective with
the film I want to show the film when
people are capable of getting the full
experience meaning with the color
corrected the sound designed in an
environment where they're actually gonna
give it some credibility the last thing
I want is to hand a DVD to somebody and
have them slap it into a laptop and
while they're on the you know subway in
the morning you know watching the film
and talking to somebody while they're
having coffee so you know as a filmmaker
you put your heart in your soul into a
project for you know a couple years and
and in the end you know you you want
someone just to give them the project a
little bit of you know respect so so I
have kind of different philosophy about
just handing out copies of the film so
you would recommend to other filmmakers
before going to AFM first off do your
research find out who's going to be
there yeah and if you research one other
types of films they've taken in and then
target the ones and also have something
to show people yeah exactly the key is
the key is research and communicating
you you really want to just get in touch
with as many people as possible and the
great thing about the AFM is you know
people may not be interested in your
film or they may not want to actually
actually well I guess they may not want
to be interested in your film but they
may just want to meet you and it's a
great opportunity because you have a lot
of veterans there and and I can get a
lot of advice for your for a future
project or even even the project you're
on and sometimes you know it's it's just
like you know everyone knows everyone so
it's just it's it's great for networking
I suppose
you